♪ ♪
>> Tucker: ANDY NGO PACIFIC
JOURNALIST FROM THE NORTHWEST,
COVERING ANTIFA QUITE A BIT.
HE WAS AT A RALLY OVER THE
WEEKEND MINDING HIS OWN BUSINESS
COVERING THE NEWS.
HE IS A JOURNALIST.
WHEN HE WAS BEATEN ALMOST TO
DEATH BY ANTIFA.
WOUND UP IN THE HOSPITAL.
HE JUST GOT OUT AND JOINS US ON
THE PROGRAM.
ANDY, I AM GLAD THAT YOU ARE
CAPABLE OF DOING THE INTERVIEW.
TOLD TELL US WHAT HAPPENED.
>> ON SATURDAY I WAS AT A
PROTEST BROUGHT TO US BY ANTIFA
ALLIES, WE WERE A STONE'S THROW
AWAY FROM PORTLAND'S MOST
IMPORTANT INSTITUTIONS OF THE
LAW, THE COURT HOUSES, THE
SHERIFF'S OFFICE, THE PRECINCT
WHILE HEARING PEOPLE CHANT "NO
HATE, NO FEAR."
I AM SUDDENLY BASHED ON THE BACK
OF MY HEAD.
FROM BEHIND.
AND FROM THERE, I AM A VERY
PASSIVE PERSON, I HAVE NEVER
BEEN IN A FIGHT, IT TOOK ME A
FEW SECONDS TO REALIZE THAT I
WAS ACTUALLY EVEN HIT IN MY HEAD
WHEN I REALIZED WHAT WAS
HAPPENING, IT WAS TOO LATE.
THE MOB OF PEOPLE ALL DRESSED IN
BLACK AND WEARING MASKS STARTED
BEATING ME WITH THEIR FISTS.
AND SOME OF THEM USE OBJECTS TO
HIT ME.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE
WERE INVOLVED.
IT SEEMED LIKE FIVE, TEN, 15, OR
20.
IT COULD'VE BEEN THAT MANY.
THEY BEAT ME SO MUCH THAT I LOST
CONTROL OF MY GOPRO CAMERA THAT
IT WAS HOLDING WHICH WAS THEN
STOLEN FROM ME, AND WHEN I
THOUGHT IT WAS OVER, I WAS
WRONG, I PUT MY ARMS UP TO TRY
TO SHIELD MY FACE AS WELL AS TO
SIGNAL TO THEM THAT I WAS
SURRENDERING, AND THAT I WAS NOT
THERE TO FIGHT, BUT IT REALLY
SIGNALED TO THEM TO BE MORE
AGGRESSIVE, SO THAN THEY STARTED
DUMPING WHAT I BELIEVE WERE
MILK SHAKES, AND EGGS, THROWING
IT AT MY FACE.
WHICH BLINDED ME SO THAT I COULD
NOT SEE.
AND I WAS KICKED SOME MORE,
PUNCHED SOME MORE.
AND ALL THIS TIME I KEPT
THINKING, WHERE THE POLICE?
I COULD STILL SEE THE COUNTY
JUSTICE CENTER IN FRONT OF ME,
BUT NO POLICE EVER ARRIVED.
I EVENTUALLY STUMBLED AWAY.
BLEEDING.
ACROSS THE PARK, AND I LOST MY
BALANCE, SO I SAT DOWN ON THE
GROUND IN FRONT OF THE
COURTHOUSE AND FROM THERE, A
MEDIC S.W.A.T. TEAM INFORMED ME
THAT IN ORDER TO GET IN AN
AMBULANCE TO BE TAKEN TO A
HOSPITAL, I WOULD HAVE TO WALK
TO THE POLICE PRECINCT, IN OTHER
WORDS, WALK BACK IN THE
DIRECTION OF THE DEMONSTRATORS
WHO JUST ATTACKED ME.
LATER THAT NIGHT AFTER ARRIVING
IN THE EMERGENCY ROOM, I HAD A
CT SCAN THAT CONFIRMED THAT I
WAS DIAGNOSED WITH A BRAIN
HEMORRHAGE.
>> Tucker: FROM WHICH YOU ARE
SUFFERING NEUROLOGICAL DAMAGE.
THIS IS A GROUP THAT CNN'S
PRIME TIME ANCHORS HAVE DEFENDED
AND PROMOTED.
I SAW THAT ANDREW YANG, WHO IS
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT AS A
DEMOCRAT ATTACKED ANTIFA FOR
THEIR SPIRIT HAVE YOU RECEIVED
ANY SUPPORT FROM ANY OTHER
DEMOCRATIC OFFICEHOLDERS IN
PORTLAND OR NATIONALLY?
>> NOT THAT I KNOW OF.
>> Tucker: NOT THAT I KNOW OF.
WHAT?
THAT TELLS YOU EVERYTHING.
AND WE ARE HAPPY THAT YOU ARE AT
LEAST CAPABLE OF JOINING US
TONIGHT.
IT IS A SHOCKING STORY.
AND ENRAGING STORY.